[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro de Sky Eco aujourd'hui je
vous propose une émission qui s'appelle
salarié au premier regard regardez
[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans salarié au
premier regard une émission tournée ce
mercredi à 19 avril au Vélodrome
national de 50 ans en Yvelines à
l'occasion du ski d'innovation et talent
le concept de ce rendez-vous est très
simple mettre en relation des candidats
de 50 ans en email avec des entreprises
et des structures d'emploi du territoire
pendant cette émission les candidats
devront pitcher chacun leur tour devant
ce fameux jury composé d'entreprises et
de structures d'emploi pendant 3 à 4
minutes pas plus ce ne sera pas simple
c'est un peu stressant mais ils vont y
arriver mais avant de parler des
candidats nous allons parler de ce
fameux jury nous avons trois personnes
dans le jury aujourd'hui on va tout de
suite les présenter nous avons Awa
Fofana de check-apay Alban Margherita de
Nos Quartiers ont des Talents et Laurie
kifouri de face 78 bonjour à tous
bonjour alors on va commencer par par où
à voix est-ce que vous pouvez présenter
votre structure bonsoir je suis Awa
Fofana donc je suis la fondatrice de
check Tapei une start-up qui a été créée
en octobre 2022 et dont la mission est
dont la mission
on est dans les aléas de du site
les salariés pour leur permettre d'être
payé au salaire le plus juste et donc
pour cela on a une plateforme digitale
qui les met en relation avec des experts
payent indépendants qui les aident à
vérifier leur bulletin de salaire et
vérifier qu'il ne manque pas de sous
mais aussi on les accompagne à travers
des prestations d'accompagnement pour
négocier leur salaire ou leurs
conditions de travail ou encore de
départ
on est situé à Guyancourt au niveau du
ski cube on va passer le micro à Alban
alors Alban même question est-ce qu'on
peut vous présenter bien sûr bonjour à
toutes et à tous ravi d'être parmi vous
aujourd'hui je suis Alban Marguerita
délégué régional de l'association NQT
alias no quartier ont des Talents notre
association existe depuis plus de 16 ans
maintenant et a été créé de façon à
proposer du mentorat aux jeunes diplômés
en recherche d'emploi d'alternance on
les met en relation concrètement avec
des cadres et des dirigeants entreprises
pour que ces personnes les coachent dans
leurs recherches c'est assez efficace
puisque sur les plus de 80 000 jeunes
que nous avons accompagnés depuis le
début de l'association
euh en moyenne au bout de six mois plus
de 70% trouve chaussures à leurs pieds
c'est-à-dire un emploi Pyrène à hauteur
de leurs qualification et nous sommes
basés partout sur le territoire français
y compris une partie des DOM et
partenaires de la de l'agglo
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines depuis cette
année à vous Laurie
bonjour donc je suis Laurie kifouri
chargée de mission emploi chez face donc
c'est la Fondation agir contre
l'exclusion c'est un club d'entreprise
socialement engagée donc nous aussi nous
accompagnons en fait les personnes en
recherche d'emploi en les mettant en
lien avec nos entreprises pour qu'ils
puissent retrouver comme Eldi Alban
chaussures à leurs pieds est-ce que vous
êtes prêt à jouer votre rôle de jury
tout à fait tout à fait vous allez être
gentil
alors maintenant présenter notre premier
candidat il s'appelle Kevin matos il
vient de nsup alors Kevin est-ce que
vous pouvez venir voilà et prendre ce
petit micro bonjour alors mettez-vous au
niveau du placement voilà juste ici
alors Kevin déjà est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter vous venez d'où vous avez
quel âge et vous recherchez quoi
et bien je m'appelle matos Kevin je
viens de Massy je suis actuellement en
Bachelor en intelligence artificielle et
j'ai 26 ans et je travaille chez
Bouygues Construction alors on va vous
donner du coup 4 minutes maximum pour
pitcher bon courage c'est parti c'est à
vous vous la regardez bien donc j'avais
commencé par une prépa tout ce qu'il y a
depuis classique et j'ai fait une école
d'ingénieurs qui s'appelle Les Arts et
Métiers et en gros pendant mon cursus
j'ai on a eu besoin de moi pour pas mal
de trucs en Python pour gérer tout ce
qui va être avec les personnes de ma
promotion puisqu'on était sans 168 et du
coup c'était plein de petits projets en
informatique avec Python qui m'ont un
peu dirigé vers là-bas et où je me suis
dit pourquoi pas essayer de
l'informatique
j'étais resté quand même aux armitiés
pendant ce temps là et
en fait je me suis dit j'adore les maths
quel est l'endroit où il y a le plus de
maths avec de l'informatique ce serait
du coup l'intelligence artificielle j'ai
commencé un peu à regarder aux alentours
pour voir tout ce qui était proposé par
les différentes choses
et j'ai commencé à beaucoup de
documenter à demander aux allumettes des
arts métiers tout ce qui pourrait être
en rapport avec Python l'intelligence
artificielle etc donc on va redirigé
vers tout ce qui était
la data science le petit massacien des
des algorithmes et du coup c'était un
truc qui m'avait pas mal intéressé du
coup j'ai commencé à chercher je suis
tombé sur l'ensitek qui justement un
Bachelor en intelligence artificielle
et qui propose après un master toujours
dans cette continuation j'ai eu la
chance du coup avec les missions à
Bouygues Construction de pouvoir faire
un peu de datation et justement gérer un
peu tous les
tout ce qui était les documents qu'on
m'avait donné on avait donné un gros
list de avec on va dire un XML où il y
avait toutes les informations du coup
fallait faire du Rivers ingénering pour
comprendre comment ça a été fait pour
après par la suite essayer d'extraire
toutes les données les remettre en dans
un dans le bonheur dans un ordre
exploitable c'est-à-dire de façon
exportable pour la suite pour
la partie informatique et aussi pour
pouvoir les présenter donc il y avait
vraiment deux versions une version que
je pouvais présenter avec des données on
va dire lisible par les humains et
d'autres où il y avait un peu plus tout
ce qui était un peu moche on va dire que
qu'on met un peu derrière et qui
permettait après justement de faire
toutes la partie difficile on va dire de
du code
c'était une expérience qui était
extrêmement enrichissante puisque
vraiment j'ai pu tâtonner j'ai pu faire
du revers ingénering de la data science
du scrapping puisque j'ai dû remettre
toutes les données à disposition et
c'était pas mal intéressant c'était
vraiment quelque chose qui m'a fait me
dire que faut que je continue par là et
vraiment avec Python pour continuer à
développer toutes mes toutes mes
connaissances et vraiment c'est quelque
chose que j'aimerais poursuivre par la
suite du coup j'ai vu que il y avait du
coup le master en intelligence
artificielle qui pourrait permettre
m'intéresser et j'ai aussi continué de
mettre documenter sur tout ce qui
pourrait être en rapport avec
l'intelligence artificielle et par
exemple une certification de
cinq Ford sur justement d'intelligence
artificielle qui paraît la suite
pourrait m'intéresser pour continuer de
progresser et du coup je suis vraiment à
la recherche de quelque chose dans la
datation
au début et pourquoi pas dans quelque
chose d'un peu plus complexe niveau
algorithme en intelligence artificielle
et voilà c'est à peu près tout
3 minutes 25 pour vous Kevin bravo vous
avez respecté le temps déjà bravo à vous
alors votre avis du côté du jury on va
commencer à par où avoir super merci
beaucoup déjà Kevin c'est pas un
exercice facile de pitcher surtout quand
j'imagine que ça devait être peut-être
ton premier Beach sur une émission de
télé donc bravo c'était vraiment pas
beaucoup de monde autour absolument pas
bravo vraiment pour cet exercice j'ai
trouvé ton pitch extrêmement intéressant
et ce qui ressort vraiment c'est cette
dimension de proactivité tu n'es pas là
à attendre que des choses se passent ou
qu'on te propose tu vas tu recherches tu
déconnes et c'est quelque chose et une
qualité qui moi qui suis une start-up et
Ben qui m'attire beaucoup chez les
candidats des gens qui sont
débrouillards qui essayent d'aller
chercher les choses donc c'est vraiment
quelque chose de très attractif en axe
d'amélioration je te recommanderais
surtout parce que tu es dans un domaine
qui est pas connu du grand nombre
l'informatique de bien penser à définir
les termes que tu utilises tu as
commencé par nous parler de Python mais
il y a pas beaucoup de monde qui savent
ce que c'est python on connaît le
serpent mais pas forcément le langage
informatique mais sinon c'était vraiment
une très belle prestation et bravo à toi
est-ce qu'il pourrait être votre salarié
au premier regard franchement tu as le
relever le défi bravo
oui Kevin m'a très très bonne
présentation franchement bravo parce que
c'est vrai qu'on est jeune comme ça
devant une assistance c'est déjà un
exercice vraiment pas évident donc tu as
vraiment relevé le défi c'est une
première chose notable après je trouve
ton storytelling très intéressant dans
la mesure où il y a un fil conducteur tu
as su faire passer l'envie tu es dans le
domaine de latex et c'est intéressant de
pouvoir faire transparaître le fait que
tu es un passionné finalement c'est ça
qu'il faut qu'il faut faire passer dans
ton message et tu l'as plutôt bien fait
donc encore une fois bravo et puis après
je dirais que moyennant quelques petites
retouches comment on a tous des petits
tics de langage forcément donc tu peux
enlever les petits du coup les trucs
très souvent en travaillant après tu vas
avoir un rendu vraiment nickel et encore
une fois bah bravo et continue merci
Lorie c'est à VOUS salarié au premier
regard ou pas bien sûr je rejoins mes
collègues donc sur politique de langage
sur bien détailler les les noms de
scientifiques que nous on connaît pas
forcément
peut-être plus accentué sur ce que ça
t'apporter tes expériences passées et
comment tu pourrais
comment dire aider à porter une
compétence en plus pour les entreprises
que tu vises et moi je voulais aussi
savoir quel type de contrat tu
recherches
et bien du coup je recherche une
alternance c'est vrai que je l'ai pas
dit du coup en data science ou data
analystes vraiment quelque chose qui est
vraiment porté sur la data et qui permet
de sur deux ans sur deux ans du coup
d'accord très bien
c'est bon pour vous merci à vous Kevin
en tout cas vous avez respecté le temps
on le répète et apparemment vous les
avez séduits donc c'est plutôt positif
merci beaucoup merci on va recevoir
maintenant notre oui on peut l'applaudir
notre deuxième candidate il s'agit
d'icia Jay vous pouvez approcher ici
alors vous nous venez de Trappes c'est
bien ça
Montigny ah il y a une petite erreur
dans mes fiches alors c'est à vous
présentez vous justement
et je suis en dernière année de Master
politique sociale était territorialisé à
l'UVSQ à Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines allez
c'est à vous où on va pitcher alors je
vais mettre le chrono dans un petit
instant
c'est parti 4 minutes maximum
donc bonjour à tous et à tous donc
aujourd'hui mes appétences et mes
diplômes ainsi que celui en préparation
je vise à priori le secteur associatif
avec idéalement une politique tournée
vers les quartiers populaires les qpv
donc quartier prioritaire de la ville le
secteur des organisations humanitaires
avec comme objectif par exemple
la lutte contre la précarité scolaire
qui est un sujet qui me tient
particulièrement à coeur pour que vous
compreniez un temps soit peu à les
raisons qui me poussent à me tourner
vers ces secteurs là plutôt que d'autres
il faut savoir du coup que je suis issue
d'une licence sociology à l'UVSQ et
qu'actuellement je suis en master PST
donc politique sociale et
territorialisée toujours à l'UV est-ce
que comme je l'ai dit tout à l'heure
mes différentes expériences
professionnelles depuis l'âge de mes 18
ans quand même
petit à petit mise en relation avec
continuer avec un public en grande
difficulté précarité sociale et
financière du coup par la même occasion
et cette cohabitation si on peut parler
de cohabitation m'a poussé à voir les
choses autrement et à me renouveler tous
les jours même aujourd'hui et donc mes
objectifs professionnels sont totalement
liées à ma vision du monde qui a
beaucoup changé ces dernières années et
ce qui me caractériserait en tant que
futur collaboratrice je dirais que c'est
l'écoute active qui peut me permettre
d'anticiper beaucoup de choses qu'elle
soit négatives ou positive
ma force de proposition si on peut
parler comme ça mon empathique qui peut
être c'est vrai considéré par certains
comme étant un frein mais à mon sens pas
du tout parce qu'il s'agit d'une qualité
parce qu'elle me permet d'être
pleinement à l'écoute et d'accompagner
au mieux mes collègues quand j'étais
collègues et les personnes avec
lesquelles je suis à travailler ensuite
ce qui ressort c'est mon implication
dans divers projets parce que c'est vrai
que j'ai beaucoup de projets
ce qui amène du coup mon entourage
familial et professionnel à remarquer
mon sens du résultat et pour finir je
dirais mon sens du collectif qui est
très souvent souligné parce que c'est
vrai que c'est une personne qui aime les
gens donc pour vous illustrer un petit
peu ce que je viens de vous dire c'est
vrai qu'il y a trois réalisations
probantes qui peuvent vous permettre de
mieux comprendre comme moi j'ai réussi
par exemple lors de mon expérience de
mon Touring à la fève du coup
a bien accompagné et faire monter en
compétences le jeûne qui m'avait été
confié durant trois ans trois ans
d'affilée
comment alors j'ai réussi en qualité
d'assistante d'éducation au sein d'un
collège repas à Guyancourt
à faire
comment dira repêcher si on peut parler
comme ça des élèves qui étaient sur le
plan d'être exclus parce que c'était un
collège dur entre guillemets en leur
redonnant envie de faire partie du
collège de la vie du collège ou bien
encore comment j'ai réussi en qualité de
vice-présidente d'une association que
j'ai co créé
donc à mener de belles actions pour les
enfants en mal de logement en leur
proposant des activités ludiques par
exemple voilà alors 3 minutes 48 bravo
vous avez respecté les les quatre
minutes et en plus en ayant eu un petit
moment un peu de compliqué au niveau de
la sonorisation alors qu'est-ce que vous
avez pensé à Awa pas facile quand même
de vu les conditions c'est ça c'est pas
les conditions les plus faciles pour
pitcher mais bravo le défi est relevé
une fois de plus salarié au premier
regard effectivement parce que moi tout
ce qui est enjeu social ça me parle et
tu as réussi à faire transparaître dans
ce pitch ta passion ton envie pour ce
secteur là donc ça c'est c'est vraiment
génial en axe d'amélioration je te
propose de faire attention à ne pas
t'auto dénigrer quand tu dis a priori
l'associatif quand tu dis ouais c'est
pas tous les gens voient pas trop comme
une qualité bah tu as des qualités mais
les en avant donc super et puis sinon
vraiment c'est très lisible tu as des
notes mais tu faisais bien attention à
regarder tout le monde et ça j'ai trouvé
ça super bravo merci Alban c'est à vous
ici bravo bravo ce que j'ai apprécié
particulièrement c'est l'approche très
pro en fait dans la construction de ton
de ton discours d'ailleurs tu t'es
équipé voilà d'un support c'est c'est
jamais négligeable et puis après tu as
aussi une démarche de vente en fait
c'est à dire que tu as essayé de faire
ressortir des traits des
caractéristiques qui appliquait au
domaine professionnel peuvent avoir du
sens et donner envie de travailler avec
toi donc ça c'est le raisonnement que tu
as appliqué là-dessus dans ta
présentation il est vraiment constructif
bravo et puis après bah tu tu te
recentre sur le concret sur ton vécu
professionnel et l'ensemble de tout ça
ça ça donne quelque chose d'assez
d'assez concluant bravo merci
c'est à vous je vous vois à chaque fois
où vous avez un petit calepin vous notez
effectivement alors un très très beau
pitch bravo encore
ce qui m'a plu aussi c'est le côté
social donc il me parle beaucoup nous on
est du coin club d'entreprise
socialement engagée donc ce qui est
tourné autour des cupides autour de
l'enfance etc ça me parle beaucoup
petite précision par rapport à toutes
tes qualités tu hésites peut-être les
illustrer par exemple voilà impliquer
dans tel projet un exemple de projet ça
permet de au recruteur de mieux
comprendre ce que tu as fait
concrètement et te positionner en force
de proposition en force de service de
compétences pour l'entreprise
salarié au premier regard bien sûr ok
merci
merci à vous ici on peut l'applaudir
merci à vous laisser le petit micro on
va maintenant passer à notre troisième
candidat Grégory et
Grégory le micro mettez vous bien là
parfait
d'où venez et qu'est-ce que vous
recherchez alors je m'appelle Grégory
j'ai 21 ans et je recherche une
alternance en mécanique modélisation et
sciences des données
c'est à vous vous allez pitcher alors je
vais remettre pareil le petit
chronomètre vous êtes prêts je suis prêt
c'est parti alors je m'appelle Grégory
je suis actuellement en licence physique
en spécialité mécanique et je recherche
une alternance pour l'année prochaine
car je suis j'espère et faire un master
en alternance à Paris Saclay dans lequel
j'ai déjà postulé et aujourd'hui on me
donne la chance d'être ici et de
rechercher une alternance et de
rencontrer de nombreuses entreprises
alors pour revenir sur mon parcours j'ai
d'abord commencé par faire un
baccolorationifique option Sciences de
l'Ingénieur car j'ai très vite été
passionné par l'ingénierie je me suis
très vite réorienté vers ça et c'est un
baccalauré qui s'est plutôt bien passé
pour moi et donc naturellement je me
suis orienté vers une classe
préparatoire aux grandes écoles
qui elle m'a apporté de nombreuses
qualités j'ai pu apprendre à parler à
bien m'exprimer devant
plusieurs personnes j'ai pu apprendre à
m'exprimer
à m'exprimer de manière claire et
concise et surtout j'ai appris à parler
vite à bien manager mon temps et aussi à
acquérir de compétences que je peux vite
réutiliser
cependant c'était un rythme qui était
très très chargé et du coup moi qui
était passionné de sciences j'avais pas
vraiment le temps d'acquérir de mes
compétences et de bien les maîtriser et
c'est pour ça que juste après je me suis
réorienté dans une dans une licence
physique dans laquelle j'ai pu
m'améliorer améliorer mes compétences et
me perfectionner et surtout aussi la
licence physique m'a permis de beaucoup
plus m'exercer de faire beaucoup de
travaux pratiques là-bas j'ai pu
utiliser de nombreux logiciels comme
comme
Katia logiciel de modélisation Solidwork
c'est aussi matelas Python qui sont des
logiciels de codage et c'est en licence
physique que je me suis découvert une
passion pour pour la mécanique je me
suis donc spécialisé en troisième année
en licence physique en mécanique et
conception sciences des données
et c'est une voix qui m'a beaucoup qui
m'a beaucoup apporté si j'ai enfin le
sentiment de savoir ce que je veux faire
précisément et c'est pour ça que
je pense être capable de faire un master
en alternance c'est vrai que la prépa et
la licence n'ont pas abordé beaucoup de
d'expérience professionnelle j'ai pas eu
vraiment l'occasion de faire beaucoup de
travaux de stage mais je me suis quand
même forcé l'été dernier à faire un
stage en bureau d'études parce que je
savais que je manquais d'expérience
professionnelle donc j'ai pu faire un
stage en bureau d'études en mécanique
là-bas j'ai j'ai su que
c'est ce que je voulais faire de ma vie
en fin de compte j'ai enfin compris que
la mécanique c'était fait pour moi et
j'ai donc aujourd'hui je me présente
devant vous pour pour obtenir un stage
un contrat en alternance qui est sur qui
est sur deux ans comme la longueur du
Master
à partir de la rentrée prochaine voilà
3 minutes 03 pour le pitch un pitch
parfaitement respecté par vous Grégory
ah ouais qu'est-ce que vous en avez
pensé bravo Grégory c'est vraiment pas
un exercice facile de pitcher dans un
endroit comme le Sky Haïti vraiment
bravo j'ai beaucoup aimé ton speech ton
speech ton pitch il était vraiment très
intéressant et surtout tu as fait
transparaître ta passion pour ce domaine
d'activité et ce que j'ai beaucoup aimé
c'est ta façon de montrer qu'on veut
pivoter et que ce n'est pas forcément un
échec mais c'est vraiment une réflexion
sur son parcours professionnel on peut
tâtonner avant de découvrir ce qui nous
correspond vraiment et donc tu as très
bien amené ça ton passage de la prépa
vers ce changement d'orientation que tu
as ensuite fait ce qui est juste un peu
dommage c'est que pour le stage tu as
dit je me suis forcée à le faire ça
aurait été mieux de dire une formulation
un petit peu plus
engageante et volontaire mais sinon tu
as eu un très très beau speech et je
vais pas arrêter explique Peach et donc
salarié au premier regard oui c'est vrai
salarié regard avec plaisir
le fameux logiciel python si je j'ai cru
entendre c'est vrai que c'est un langage
de programmation qui revient beaucoup en
classe préparatoire
c'est quelque chose que que Alban et moi
forcément avons pratiqué Alban
Grégory bravo bonne présentation ce que
j'ai apprécié par dessus tout c'est ton
entrée en matière qui était très très
carré et puis après surtout on comprend
bien ton parcours ce que tu veux en
faire tu t'es appuyé aussi c'est ça qui
ajoute de la valeur sur sur ton vécu tu
le fais bien transparaître donc ça c'est
une très bonne chose et puis après comme
axe d'amélioration effectivement pouvoir
encore te préparer davantage aux pistes
on a senti parfois que tu étais un petit
peu un petit peu aux limites mais tu
peux peut-être pratiquer des petits
exercices de respiration par exemple
avant de pitcher pour être bien encore
plus à l'aise et à partir de là je pense
que tous les ingrédients sont bons mais
je dirais oui salariés au premier regard
merci Lorie salariés au premier regard
pour vous aussi tout à fait très beau
pitch pour moi pour ma part juste une
petite un petit exagération c'est le je
pense être capable vous êtes capable
positionnez-vous en tant que offrir de
compétences et ça sera ça merci beaucoup
parfait merci à vous Grégory on va
maintenant passer à notre on l'applaudit
quatrième et dernier candidat plutôt
candidate Clara scheng tenait voici le
micro mettez-vous bien voilà vous placez
vous bien super
est-ce que vous pouvez vous présenter
déjà rapidement en quelques secondes
alors je m'appelle Clara Cheng j'ai 21
ans je suis ici aujourd'hui pour
rechercher une entreprise en alternance
pour intégrer un master qualité hygiène
santé sécurité environnement parfait
alors on va
partir pour 4 minutes de pitch maximum
je le répète c'est parti c'est à vous
alors concernant mon parcours
professionnel j'ai effectué la totalité
de ma scolarité en alternance afin de
découvrir le monde de l'entreprise donc
en 2019 j'ai intégré un BTS Gestion des
petites entreprises dans une entreprise
qui s'appelle aromatum spécialisé dans
le sourcing d'épices à l'international
donc j'avais un poste assez polyvalent
je m'occupais de la comptabilité des
ressources humaines mais également de
l'administration des ventes j'avais
également pour mission de m'occuper du
renouvellement de la certification ISO
91 donc par la suite en 2021 j'ai
poursuivi vers une licence management
des organisations toujours en alternance
chez fast Yvelines donc un club
d'entreprise socialement engagé qui agit
au niveau local donc en tant que Charlie
gestion je m'occupais principalement
d'être en support des différents pôles
notamment dans l'organisation
d'événements ou dans l'animation des
réseaux sociaux j'avais également une
mission qui était aidé la structure à se
développer au niveau digital donc c'est
passé par la mise en place de logiciels
de gestion que ce soit pour la gestion
des absences ou pour tout ce qui est
gestion des partenaires et j'ai
également mis en place une charte de
télétravail
donc suite à mes précédentes expériences
j'ai pris la décision de me spécialiser
dans le domaine de la qualité via une
licence qualité hygiène Santé Sécurité
Environnement donc faciline m'a de
nouveau fait confiance pour que je
puisse mettre un passe la certification
kyopie au sein du service formation donc
à l'hôpital c'est une certification pour
le développement des compétences donc ma
mission c'était de mettre en conformité
le service au référentiel donc dans un
premier temps j'ai entamé un état des
lieux et un diagnostic du système donc
suite à ça dans un second temps j'ai
construit et animé le système donc c'est
passé par une cinquantaine de documents
que ce soit des modes opératoires des
procédures des processus mais également
des enregistrements et par la suite j'ai
organisé et animer les audits à blanc et
de certification donc depuis février
2023 nous sommes certifiés kaliopie donc
sans aucune non conformité que ce soit
majeur ou mineur
et à ce jour ma mission est d'assurer le
maintien de la certification et notre
système de management de qualité et
d'être en support sur tout ce qui est
gestion des risques donc je m'occupe du
document unique d'évaluation des risques
professionnels et du plan d'action
associé donc que ce soit délivré
d'accueil sécurité ou d'autres actions
en lien avec
par exemple dérèglement intérieur ou des
choses comme ça donc en règlement
combien de ma formation j'ai également
obtenu la certification d'auditeur
interne avec une première expérience en
tant que responsable d'audit dans une
entreprise de logistique à Valence
et en résumé donc ces quatre années
d'expérience professionnelle m'ont
permis de développer des compétences
transversales et de prendre connaissance
des grandes fonctions de l'entreprise et
je suis désormais prête dès septembre
2023 à contribué à l'amélioration des
pratiques des entreprises donc en me
spécialisant dans le domaine de la
qualité que ce soit dans
l'agroalimentaire l'industrie ou dans
tout ce qui est service voilà et je
voudrais également trouver une
entreprise peut-être un peu plus grande
autour de plus de 100 salariés voilà et
j'aimerais aussi découvrir tout ce qui
est gestion des risques et santé
sécurité au travail
presque 3 minutes pour vous exactement
c'était le but de l'exercice on a dit
entre 3 et 4 minutes vous êtes
exactement à 2 minutes 58 bravo à vous
alors on va passer maintenant aux
réactions du jury à Awa bravo à toi
c'est le premier regard oui alors je
pense que c'est moi qui serait pas la
boîte au premier regard parce que pour
l'instant j'ai un personne mais donc
j'ai une rempli pas le critère d'essence
salariés mais un jour pourquoi pas
bravo pour ce pitch c'était vraiment
très bien on sent que tu as bien préparé
que tu as bien orchestré et planifier en
fait tes missions pour nous montrer on
voit que pour une jeune qui demande une
alternance et bien tu as une vraie
expérience en axe d'amélioration ce que
je te proposerai c'est plutôt que de
nous faire un relevé de tout le passé et
de toutes les expériences de miser vers
l'avenir et de dire ce que tu peux
apporter aux entreprises et plutôt de
faire un lien à chaque fois entre chaque
expérience et comment elle peut se
matérialiser dans l'entreprise que tu
vas rejoindre pour vraiment apporter
cette plus-value mais très clairement on
se dit on va voir quelqu'un qui a déjà
fait plein de choses ISO qualiopie et
donc il va pouvoir apporter plein de
compétences en entreprise donc ça donne
vachement envie merci Alban c'est à vous
bravo une nouvelle fois je pense que ce
qui ressort de ta présentation si la
fluidité du discours
et je pense que c'est pas lié au hasard
tu as choisi délibérément de finalement
de suivre une présentation par ordre
chronologique et du coup ça facilite
cette fluidité dans le discours donc
bravo le tweet inconvénient c'est
effectivement ce que ce que Awa a cité
c'est à dire que c'est un peu tourné
vers le passé mais si on comprend bien
qu'il faut de la matière pour pouvoir
illustrer tes savoir-faire que tu vas
mettre sur le marché aujourd'hui mais
voilà peut-être plus redéployer
redévelopper la dernière partie de ta
présentation pour mieux te vendre
finalement et répondre aux attentes de
des personnes que tu vas rencontrer dans
tes processus de recrutement mais encore
une fois bravo
Lorie est-ce que le calepin est plein ou
il reste encore de la place
plus de place du tout
excellent pitch pour moi très bien
orchestré alors attention juste à ton
débit de parole elle est moins vite et
tout sera tout sera parfait
merci beaucoup merci à vous à Clara on
peut on peut l'applaudir merci à vous
alors tous les candidats sont passés une
petite réaction peut-être Lorie vu que
vous avez le micro sur cette émission
qu'est-ce que vous en avez pensé alors
c'est un très bel exercice pour pour ces
jeunes Jeanne qui débute leur carrière
et je pense que le faire en plus devant
une télé c'est pas facile
ils s'en sont tous très bien sortis et
qu'on sent effectivement qu'il y a
beaucoup de travail derrière avant de
pouvoir pitcher
bravo à eux déjà d'avoir répondu présent
parce que on les a pas non plus menacés
pour qu'il soit là présent donc c'est
qu'il y avait de la matière au départ
pour qu'ils puissent se projeter sur
cette expérience et c'est vrai qu'à
l'orage c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
excellent ce qu'ils ont pu ce qu'ils ont
pu rendre donc on pourrait que les
encourager à persévérer moi je suis
persuadé que tous vont vraiment trouver
à une solution très rapidement parce
qu'on sent que vraiment voilà ce sont
pourrait les aider à bien entendu il y a
déjà ici qui qui est chez nous mais
effectivement
on ne saurait on pourrait que les
encourager à prendre la suite et prendre
contact avec notre association aussi
avec face bien entendu qui a qui propose
des choses assez identiques donc encore
une fois bravo et persévérer vous êtes
sur la bonne voie félicitation
Awa pour clôturer oui bravo à tout le
monde vous avez vraiment assuré et moi
Étienne j'accompagne les salariés au
cours de leur carrière et il y a une
chose que vous avez compris je pense
avant les autres c'est la proactivité
c'est le fait de sortir des sentiers
battus c'est pas forcément habituel pour
les jeunes de venir pitié dans une
émission pour aller trouver leur
entreprise et vous avez choisi quelque
chose d'atypique vous allez sortir du
lot et donc c'est vraiment un esprit qui
vous faut conserver pour la suite de
votre carrière donc je m'inquiète pas du
tout bon courage et très belle
continuation professionnelle à vous tous
ça sera le mot de la fin alors c'est
déjà la fin de salariés au premier
regard merci à tous les participants
jury également aux candidats merci
également à vous de nous avoir suivi
pendant ces 30 minutes d'émissions à
bientôt sur TV 78
[Musique]